what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for an interview I know many of
you are looking forward to I am the
director of Winnie the Pooh Blood and
Honey right now Reese Frank Waterfield
dude congratulations on the movie and
this like wild and somewhat
unprecedented ride it has taken you on
oh thanks so much yeah thanks for having
me he's been so exciting we've um
yesterday was the day we've released to
the world so like it's approximately in
4 000 screens or so which is absolutely
wild I had the pleasure of seeing it on
one of those screens with a very
enthusiastic audience and I know that
usually you don't release your films
theatrically but this film to me feels
like it's got perfect uh you know
midnight communal horror loving Vibes
where everyone is there and they know
what they're getting into
yeah so we kind of um made this like
normally our our business model we did a
lot of like straight to VOD
um and DVD films at the start
um and but since then we've started to
like up the quality and make them kind
of better and more kind of like
action-packed um and now yeah we're
starting to get interest with some of
these films for like theaters like I
thought Winnie the Pooh had the
potential to um go to do a small
theatrical run but it's just gone blown
way out of proportion
it's not a small run at all
apparently when you put a knife in
Winnie the Pooh's hands it just it
brings the viewers in it brings the
audience who would have thought
um I want to learn a little bit about
you as a filmmaker before we jump into
the specifics here so looking at your
IMDb I saw you made a couple shorts in
2014 but then there was nothing until
2021 and at that point you produce
something like seven features and it
seems like you're producing more and
more ever since so what happened between
2014 and 2021 that put you on that track
so um actually I used to be in a
completely different industry so uh I
used to work in corporate strategy for
like a big multinational energy company
and they were called EDF energy so I
think you guys have them in the US
um and so I did that for about eight or
nine years and kind of my my partner was
um kind of in the film industry so I
kind of like through osmosis started
learning about it and getting more and
more interested in it and then yeah
approximately about two years ago I just
thought I'm just going to give it a go I
just quit my job and then just started
doing it and yeah those those films on
idb they're actually it's actually even
more mad than that because they were um
a lot of them have been like they're
just waiting and they're in like the
post-production pipeline so they've
already been filmed and we're just kind
of doing the last minute tweaks before
they can get released but in those two
years alone I think I might have
produced about 40 or 50 feature films
all of which
um yeah have got kind of worldwide
distribution and then since then it's
now yeah it's a bit more quality focused
now reducing down the number so I'm
doing about or probably producing about
four this year
um Winnie was one last year
I've got winnie2 we've got Bambi we've
got Peter Pan and a secret project
I have produced One feature film in the
horror genre and I'll tell you I I think
I needed to sleep for like a whole month
after shooting that movie so I am so
incredibly impressed that you can do
this non-stop it really is something
else oh thanks so much yeah a lot of
people call these um Productions like
heart attack Productions at least for
like the producers because like you're
constantly manically going from one set
to the next and you're having to wear a
lot of hats so like it was like that I'm
winning actually I was um that's why I'm
kind of like the producer writer
director I did like drones on the set as
well and like VFX supervising just yeah
hands and loads of pots
all right I have some I have a bunch of
questions here about the uh the micro
budget horror filmmaking structure
because like I'm steeped in this
industry 24 7. I do love to focus on
horror but I feel like that's a corner
the business that I don't know it's it's
shrouded in more mystery to me than I
ever realized it was so a couple
questions on that I believe this is um
itn's first theatrical release so can
you kind of walk us through when a movie
you're making is not going to the big
screen where do those movies actually go
how can people see those yeah so all the
other ones they um essentially the the
model we make them we like the
filmmakers and we're from the UK and
then ITN RL kind of us partners
um we hand the film over to those guys
and then they handle the the worldwide
distribution of it and normally that
includes kind of straight to DVD so for
example warm up a lot of these will be
in Walmart superstores and then you've
got all the foreign sales as well so
they'll sell it to loads of different
foreign territories and then you've got
the VOD element so streaming online so
and then all of that compiles to gamma
to help generate some profit okay okay
so so speaking of the Prophet I'm going
to try to stop myself short of asking
for like specific numbers here but I am
curious uh what your barometer is in
terms of how how you guys figure out
that something is successful I guess
more so than anything I'm trying to wrap
my head around you know how many viewers
you guys like to reach compared to the
more traditionally uh released horror
movies that you know we're kind of used
to assessing via box office and and
other uh other data like that yeah so we
we don't really get viewing numbers
because all that really happens is you
know like we'll make the film hand it
over to them and then those guys they're
just in charge will basically trying to
make as much money as they can uh from
it so we don't have massive visibility
around the kind of quantity of people
it's been exposed to however like it is
in the millions
um it goes to and it goes to loads of
different territories
um so we're always getting people
message us about it
um but yeah it's uh it is quite it is
quite far-reaching it's just not got
that theatrical component at the start
um but everything else is probably very
similar to what it is in a normal kind
of filming structure but just listen on
that I'm so fascinated by all this
um speaking speaking of things like like
VOD and streaming and do correct me if
I'm wrong on this but I believe I read
somewhere that after the images in the
trailer went viral you guys did get some
interest from Studios and streaming
services so why not go that route and
instead stick with I believe it's fathom
and and the way that you're Distributing
the movie now yeah so there was a few
there was a discussion we had with the
distributor about that because yeah one
option was we had some very large
companies
um some of the biggest you can probably
imagine message us and us just to buy it
outright
um and take over all the rights but we
thought okay that's
it wasn't for a huge amount
um and we thought the film had a lot of
potential
um so we thought we will start off with
a theatrical route see how that does
um and then we'll look more towards kind
of our traditional model after which is
like the DVD the VOD
um element there but since those offers
it's just continued to get bigger and
bigger and bigger
um after the steals after the trailer
um every every week it's just been like
growing in size which is yeah mad and it
got culminated in it being the second
most anticipated film this year
so I'm glad we didn't just hand it over
to someone yeah it's ultimately a smart
move right there
um so I I am curious did anything about
the movie change after everything went
viral was there anything about the viral
response that made you want to go back
and and alter or enhance anything that
people were kind of gravitating towards
yeah so we had quite a limited amount of
resources and budget for the um the
principal photography so the intention
at the start was you know make it as
good as possible
um I thought it would have a small
theatrical run but then as soon as the
Stills started going online it got
bigger and bigger and bigger and then
that's when we had this moment when oh
my God would be better um like there's
going to be a lot of people watching
this so we need to make this as good as
we can and then that's when we got some
more kind of money and resources coming
in and then we did some reshoots and
added a load of more fun scenes and made
a quiet kind of action dream really
because I really wanted the fact that I
really wanted it to be so when you went
to see how many other people horror film
you see a lot of Winnie the Pooh I
didn't want him to just be in the film
for like 20 or 25 minutes which is
probably what it would have been if it
was left to the principal photography so
uh now he's in like I think he's in like
50 minutes of the movie something crazy
did you see a lot I can confirm that
um backtracking even more what would you
say is the biggest difference between
how you originally conceived this idea
playing out like day one when the idea
first crossed your mind and what we
actually see in the finished film
screening in theaters now yeah so one of
the biggest changes was when you're
producing these ones you have to take um
comments from like some other some of
the other execs and take over what
everyone's criticism on board and uh
suggestions so we did that and it became
a bit of a um a kind of less focused on
Christopher Robin on Winnie the Pooh and
more kind of a typical kind of Cabin in
the Woods kind of slasher route then
once it kind of started going really
viral
um I really wanted there to be to really
strengthen the relationship between
Christopher and Pooh and integrate that
more into the story because for me
that's like that's basically what the
story is it's Christopher's ampu's
relationship I didn't want it to be
limited to one part of the film
um so that's why you now see him
featured throughout all of those scenes
were basically reshoots but additional
photography I should say not reshoots
yeah
very interesting
because that is something that is
threaded through the entirety of the
film yeah
um for for anyone else out there who
wants to make a horror movie on a micro
budget is there any like I I guess like
a number one do and number one don't in
terms of how to figure out how to best
use and maximize such a small budget
yeah I'd say like the most important
thing is the the concept and the the
hook straight away that needs to be
really strong and because that's the
first thing people are going to see is
also what your Distributors are going to
rely on to to actually sell the film so
if it's something really weak and it's
just I don't know that they're like a
random witch film or like a zombie film
there's a lot of those floating around
they're not unique there's um they've
probably got like five other people
pitching them try and come up with
Concepts which really stand out and
ideally yeah if you can draw on elements
like the public domain and there's other
ways of doing this outside of it just
being public domain too which um
you can like link towards your story
because that will have a really
um strong that's a really strong IP and
it's a really good resource for them for
marketing
um and it will really and that will
ultimately help that when the products
on the actual shelf in like a store like
Walmart so people will look at go oh I
know that nursery rhyme I know that
Fable
um and I haven't seen that concept
before so I'm more interested in buying
it now rather than it just being a low
budget zombie film you bring up the
public domain and I'm curious about
where you cross the line in that respect
even if something is in the public
domain when it comes to Winnie the Pooh
in particular can you give us an example
of something you needed to kind of keep
in check to adhere to what you were
actually allowed to use versus stepping
over that line and you know jumping into
what maybe another Studio has ownership
of right now yeah so yeah we had to be
very careful I had to be very careful
when I was doing this so I looked at the
um 1926 book and only read that as my
reference essentially and then just drew
went off on tangents and just got
inspired by that
um because anything which was created
post then is still under the copyright
of Disney
um so for example you've got tigar
um he was allowed to be in it
um the way Pooh speaks as well like
that's obviously not in the book
um and that sort of tone which everyone
links to Winnie the Pooh is um is there
is there copyright really like that's
their kind of branding with him so I
couldn't use that I couldn't use phrases
like obova I couldn't put the red
t-shirt on him so there are a lot of
these elements where you just need to be
really really careful with because if
you make a mistake there and you make
the film and if I had accidentally got
hit put Tigger in the film or going to
say obolver a lot I would be really
encroaching on their their copyright and
their branding then and then that would
have probably caused a lot of issues
with uh getting this released oh I have
so many questions that I think are
teetering into spoilers we're gonna get
there but before I put up the spoiler
warning for everyone I'm just curious
for you as a filmmaker let's say you
could put a horror spin on any other IP
out there and public domain was not an
issue you could have your pick of
anything you wanted what would you pick
I've really been excited by Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles lately because I
think they're like they really like the
story has a very kind of horrifying
undertone anyway because it's these
these half human half Turtles who live
in the sewer who have a kind of rat king
who they follow and then they come out
of the sewer with weapons and it all
just like it all just starts to link
together to me so um I'd love I'd love
to do that I'd love to have them like
down the alleyway cutting people up
feeding them to their racking on pizza
or something so yeah I hope I can get
the compromise from that but I don't
know if I can until it's I'm never gonna
unsee these Vision oh my God god dude
yes I wanted to tell you something
I want to see both of these so badly
those are genius ideas all right I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna put up the spoiler
warning for our viewers right now if you
have not seen Winnie the Pooh Blood and
Honey go seek it out you push pause on
this video and then after you've seen
the movie you come right back to it and
push play and it begins right here it is
that easy all right this is it one and
only spoiler warning
um okay my first question and I know
you've answered this to an extent before
but I'm curious like the detail and and
kind of like the Bible of you know what
poo and piglet are so I I guess for
clarity's sake here they they are not
human beings in masks right yeah that's
right yeah so and that's what a lot of
people really wanted like when they
first got excited by it
um there was a lot of comments out there
saying oh this isn't just like I don't
know like your next or so where it's
some Killers who have put on the put on
the mask and then doing the home
invasion now this is actually Winnie the
Pooh and piglet going around killing
people so and that's what's so exciting
about it it's so different and yeah so
in in your mind what exactly are they
they are are they some sort of like
humanoid uh like bear human mashup type
thing like what what is on their insides
and I'll take any little detail you have
so yeah they're kind of I hate this word
and I might not be able to say
anthropomorphic
um basically hot hybrids like half bear
half man and half pig half man so that
was a decision because I really wanted
them to have the ability to like hold
weapons so if I made Winnie the Pooh
just a bear he's got Paws all he'll do
is go around swiping people and killing
them maybe buy them so um but with hand
it becomes so much more fun because he
has weapons he can drive a car I can do
all these really in interesting things
and yeah inside they they are a mix of
kind of you know
human and a kind of Pooh Bear interior
so they've got the blood the go outside
but there's a bit of fluff floating
around as well and there's actually a
moment in the film if you watch
carefully when he is hit by so I'm
allowed to sell this honor because the
spoilers are done oh yes go for it he's
after he's been hit by the car and he's
slept over it you'll see
um Christopher goes to save Maria and
then he coughs and when he coughs if you
look carefully fluffs coming out so it's
blood and fluff which is he's throwing
off on the uh Bonnet
it's very subtle that would be fun what
are their limitations in terms of poo
and piglet like in terms of their
ability to survive did you kind of like
map out or create a maximum in terms of
what they could withstand and I don't
know maybe if Pooh is even Immortal in a
sense so yeah Pooh is a bit of a
juggernaut you can see he goes the
amount he goes through gets hit by a car
and even that only creates a bit of a
limp on his leg for a moment so he's
very very difficult to stop and I'm
gonna flesh out more
how difficult he is to uh to to hold off
in the sequel I think so people you
could see was a bit bit easier to uh to
take control of so piglet is dead dead
in your in your eyes Piggly it's not
dead no okay
yeah you can't kill piglet he's uh him
and Pooh are kind of the the original
two and I'm then in the sequel going to
add a few more characters in with him so
they're gonna go around and they'll be
as a group killing people how about
their powers so we see that Pooh can
control bees did you ever develop like a
similar type of power that maybe piglet
could have had so piglet I tried to give
them all differing weapons so piglet
always had like he walks around and he
loves his sledgehammer and um he's
always got the chains around him as well
and he loves to like when he ties up the
girl he like hog ties her and I hope
that was a nice link to him being a pig
but he hasn't got
a kind of at the moment well at least in
the first one we didn't really establish
a power with him with pooh obviously
there's that moment where he's
controlling bees and I thought the whole
B Dynamic was really interesting just to
put in there and see what people thought
about it you know I can remove it and
the second one if people don't like it
but um there's a lot of points
throughout the film where
you'll know his little bees are flying
around or they're um sorts placed in
certain areas so one particular example
is when Natasha's in the jacuzzi and
she's enjoying herself there's a little
bee Which flies in and then it flies off
it's basically scouted out the area for
Pooh found her
and then gone back and told Pooh and
said Natasha's in the jacuzzi go and get
her and then shortly after Pooh appears
so they're kind of like they're kind of
like his Scouts but then at the end
there's that moment where he obviously
controls a swarm of them so which I hope
people get someone told me they thought
it was dust and I thought that made no
sense
it's meant to be bees I didn't even need
a swarm I needed one b and I'd be able
to see it and I think it's because that
that's like my one big irrational fear
is B so all I need to hear is the
slightest buzzword think I caught a
glimpse of one and I I've got it and my
mind goes down that path
how about in terms of their end goal
like I I understand how Christopher
Robin put them on this path but do they
have an end goal in mind or is it more
so just like killing for the sake of
killing out out of out of anger and and
heartbreak I guess so for Pooh the
then it's kind of Christopher's always
been the one he's kind of struggled to
um really get to the point of killing
and you can really see that in the
torture scene like he's he's hitting him
he'll cause him pain but he never goes
to that that level
um or to that extreme so I've kind of
imagined his
um like his his motive behind all of
this is essentially caused Christopher
as much heartache and Agony as he can
which is why he's really brutal to him
at points and you can see you know when
he's watching what he does to his his
like engaged wide he then showers him in
blood he then whips him
and then at the end was the girl uh with
Maria as they're having their intimate
moment he just wants to kill her in
front of him he's trying to cause a lot
of suffering to Christopher and that's
what's going to be fleshed out more in
the second all right so bringing up the
the second film and I'll I'll wind down
here it read a quote from Scott
somewhere and it was something to the
effect of like if you do something and
it works and it works well don't change
it but I've also read that you guys are
gonna have five times the budget on the
sequel so why did uh Winnie the Pooh
Blood and Honey sequel demand that kind
of change even though what you had
worked so it was really challenging what
we had on the on the first one I don't
think many people will kind of believe
how yeah how how little budget we had to
work with
um and the thing is is we I feel like
we've done really really really well and
so does the crew and cast and a lot of
people relative to what we had and I
know like when it goes up more it will
really open up a lot more
um a lot of other possibilities for me
because when I'm writing and I'm coming
up with these Death Scenes I'm I've
always got because I've got a bit of
producer's hat on so I'm a bit kind of
mindful of the budget and I'm like hey I
need to limit it to this sort of area
but then when it becomes larger those
possibilities expand more and now I can
do a lot more fun deaths and we can have
more deaths we can do crazier things and
just make it even more more entertaining
okay so sign me up for that I'll I'll
end with this one here because you just
mentioned that like people will not
believe how little you had to work with
to pull this all off can you pinpoint
one specific thing in the movie that on
the day of filming even made you guys go
like I don't think we could do this with
with the small amount of resources that
we have but you found a creative way to
to tackle it and you did it yeah there
was um there was one scene I really
wanted to do and that was having poo
climbing on the car and I wanted him to
like be holding onto the back of the car
getting driven around and they saw as
the girls are trying to drive off like
Mary and Jessica and you know he's
making his way up and he's trying to
break into the wind speeds and everyone
was telling me on the like the days
before you can't do it like you know we
don't have the money there's there's not
really a way and then I was I was
telling no we can just pull man's
process it which basically means the car
is completely stationary and you have
the people in the car but everyone kind
of rocks it you add some smoking make
the smoke blow past so it looks like
it's moving and you just frame out the
stuff around and that's exactly what we
did so all of that scene bar one shot is
completely stationary and I think it
works really well it's like one of the
like it's one of my favorite little bits
of it
it's very impressive before I let you go
I'll just shout out also the lighting in
this movie at points is just like it's
stunning you have some especially
beautiful frames where the light is
positioned just in the perfect spot and
it makes for it makes for like a printed
out and hang it up on the wall kind of
frame oh thanks so much yeah I'll give a
big shout out to my uh Director of
Photography then that's uh last event's
diet and yeah we've worked with him on
many films now and yeah he's absolutely
amazing so yeah and I couldn't agree
more all right well I I mean this is
like the exciting thing about a movie
like this we could talk about it all day
it's just fun to like think about and to
theorize where things could go from here
so huge congratulations and I cannot
wait to see the next chapter for Pooh
and Piglet and whoever else you add to
this film oh thanks so much thanks for
your time